hello and welcome to my Python tutorial
series concerning math and stock
indicators within the Python programming
language quick caveat here the series is
for educational use only so the main
purpose here is to teach you how do you
do like complex mathematical equations
or semi complex mathematical equations
within Python so many people enjoy or
have a passion for a technical analysis
with stocks so I've chosen to do it with
stock prices mostly just because there's
a whole lot of formulas that are
popularly used with stocks Forex futures
and there's a lot you can learn by just
practicing mathematical equations for
these kinds of things and you can apply
this kind of skill to all kinds of
formulas in the future as well even if
you're not doing stocks Forex features
or whatever so with that the series is
not intended to induce anybody to take
part in actual trading right so this is
just educational to show you how it's
done
but beyond that it's not my
responsibility to watch over you so yet
so this is just purely educational use
only so with that let's go ahead and get
started
for the most part of this series I'm
going to be doing everything in three
main parts per formula to start I'm
going to show you a couple formulas
really quick just because there's very
basic but most of the time it's going to
be first explaining the indicator
showing it to you or the formula of what
its point is how it's used the variables
within it maybe some history if there's
anything special there then I'm going to
show you how to program that formula
into Python just very basic how to do it
and with that since that's kind of
second mention of Python here or third
it's not going to be required that you
know anything about Python at all you
can just follow along you're going to
need to download Python in the numpy
dependency but you won't have to start
this with any knowledge of programming
or Python at all it's my intention kind
of the if this is your interest that
maybe this will be the way that you can
you can learn the Python programming
language itself so so yeah you won't
need that I'll show you how to download
I thought and how to use it at least for
the purpose of this series and so yeah
hopefully uh hopefully to work out even
if you don't know any programming
language I try to explain everything as
I go along
and also Python is pretty new friendly
to start with so after showing you the
basic example of programming the
equation into Python I'm going to show
you an incorporation of that into our
map plot live finance charting
application that we built in another
series on those videos I'll include that
script that you want to edit and just
for purposes here I'll show you the
actual script itself so this is the
script that we have and you can put
anything in here so let's say we want to
graph Apple we put in the stock price or
the ticker for Apple and here's our
chart that we made if that looks
interesting you guys we've got an entire
series starting absolutely from scratch
to how to generate this chart exactly
like this so for this series we're not
going to be getting into how how this
was all done we're just going to get
into the calculation and the displaying
of that data and so what we're going to
end up doing is replacing right down
here we're going to take out the MACD
and we're going to put all our formulas
down here so we can actually depict what
we've been working on so that's what
we'll be doing this code is going to be
live on my website so I'll show you how
to download that code I'm going to exit
out of this here so to get get the code
to that just go to syntax comm and then
go slash starting point but make sure
you capitalize that P otherwise you're
not going to get the file hit enter and
then I'll take you to the full source
code of what I was just showing you it's
going to come empty without the MACD
eventually in this series will cover the
MACD as well and all of our programming
will be between these lines whenever we
add it to the code so you'll just type
it right up in in here so anyway that's
that literally just you know highlight
copy and paste this into a Python script
so now if you don't have python you'll
need to come over here go to download so
it's python org and then download
and then you're going to need not three
three or and I want to download two
seven for whatever you have if you're on
a Mac download that you're on a Windows
download your Windows installer once
you've done that the next thing we need
is numpy the easiest way to install
numpy is with an installer and that
would be over here and I will provide a
link to all of this stuff in the
description but this is the website I
would download it numpy from because it
comes in an installer so if you
downloaded a 64-bit version of python
you would use you would download this
one AMD 64 if you downloaded a 32-bit
version of python you would download
this one right here again I'll put the
links in the description so once you're
all done downloading Python you should
be able to go to your Start bar and
literally type in Python and you should
be able to get there should be something
called IDL e in Python GUI in the
parentheses or Python command line so
let's go ahead and click on the one that
says IDL e for Python GUI you'll click
that and this will come up as you can
see if you don't know what bit version
you download it'll say it right here I
have a 64-bit version of Python so now
to get yourself from this point to the
window that we're going to be developing
in you'll want to go to file new window
and that will open up like a blank one I
won't Slyke a notepad right and this
would be an example of what we would
type our program into so just for the
purposes this program you're real basic
it's just going to print hi whenever
it's ran into savings it's an untitled
program you'll want to go to file save
as obviously and then you'll get a
window here where you want to save it
for now let's just I'll put it on my
desktop and and then we'll come down
here and what you it's hard to remember
to do it you only have to do it one time
but what you want to do is you want to
literally type in you know where you
want to save it so let's just say you
know tutorial right but don't you save
this tutorial make sure you add dot py
at the end otherwise it won't
automatically save it as a Python file
and it'll come up just like a notepad
file so it's very annoying so if you
save it as dot py that'll be all
hunky-dory for you you're all done
finally last thing before we conclude
this video and actually get into some
pro
gramming to run the script you can
either go click on run and run module or
you can just hit f5 on your keyboard so
I'm going to do that a lot you might not
see like how the heck am i running the
script so I'll hit f5 that runs a script
very simple script it just prints out hi
so that should cover everything that you
need to do this series I don't think
we'll be using anything else besides I
guess we're actually going to use Matt
plot live with this let me look at the
source code again and make sure that's
the only other thing that we add in here
and pylab so we need we need to get that
so if you come back over to this website
here again I'll put the links and this
is the description I believe they have
PI level and make sure not pylab here
steam at lib area right here you can at
least download matplotlib from here so
I'll put that link in the description
finally you're going to need to get a
high lab because we are using PI lab
actually let me make sure that's a 100%
dependency of this script alright it's
actually it's just been a long time
since I first installed matplotlib so as
far as I'm aware it looks like PI lab
actually is comes bundled with Matt plot
lives so they're one in the same so as
long as you download matplotlib that's
PI lab if that isn't the case someone
can comment comment here but as long as
you have that that's good the other
thing you can do is you can download see
if this even has it Python see it here
you can download here we go like this
like Python XY that comes with oh it
comes with like a bunch of cool
applications and modules for Python but
at least for this tutorial series it's
not totally necessary anyway if anybody
has any trouble downloading and getting
everything necessary to run the script
that's on my website leave a comment
below and I'll be sure to help y'all out
figure out what's going on so anyway you
should be able to take this and so for
example with our tutorial right here
should be able to just you know
literally just do a control a
that come over here paste and you should
have no problem
f5 save it to run it and this should pop
up for you like this you put in whatever
you want to graph and you should get a
graph up here if that's not happening
for you and this should be empty right
so it won't have the MACD that we had in
there before
if this isn't happening for you guys
leave a comment below and we'll get that
we'll get it figured out
whatever's going wrong so anyway stay
tuned for the next videos didn't intend
this to be as long as it was there's a
lot of little stuff to mention before we
get get into it so anyway thanks for
watching thanks for the support and
subscriptions and until next time